- En 2010, les ruches installées
à Montréal se comptaient
sur les doigts d'une main.
Aujourd'hui, il y en aurait
autour d'un millier sur
les toits des entreprises,
des résidences ou des bâtiments
publics, comme ici, au palais
des congrès. La question :
y a-t-il maintenant trop
d'abeilles sur le territoire
de la métropole?
L'entreprise Alvéole gère plus
de 350 ruches en milieu urbain.
ALEXANDRE McLEAN, président
et cofondateur, Alvéole
- Une indication qu'il y aurait
eu trop de ruches aurait voulu
dire une perte de production,
donc moins de kilos produits de
miel, et on le voit pas. À tous
les ans, on a une production
qui est à peu près stable.
L'année passée, on a eu
une année un peu plus difficile,
ça arrive, mais cette année,
on le voit, on arrive dans
des productions record.
- Alvéole concentre surtout
ses activités dans les quartiers
centraux de la ville.
L'espace dont dispose
les abeilles d'une ruche
pour se nourrir est, en général,
pas mal plus limité que les
ruches installées en campagne.
- J'ai 30 ruches...
- En fait, il est trop limité,
selon Alain Péricard, qui a des
ruches en Estrie et à Montréal.
ALAIN PÉRICARD, apiculteur
- Ce que je constate,
c'est qu'avec les mêmes
méthodes, je récolte peut-
être... 1/5 ou 1/6 du miel
que je récolte à la campagne
avec les même abeilles.
- L'un des problèmes que pose
le manque d'espace, dit-il,
c'est que les abeilles
trop à l'étroit ont tendance à
essaimer, à créer de nouvelles
ruches, et parfois, à devenir
plus agressives.
- Il y a une personne
sur 5000 qui peut subir un choc
anaphylactique à cause
d'une piqûre d'une abeille.
S'il y a trop de ruches,
les ruches vont avoir tendance
à essaimer et, d'une certaine
facon, ça peut mettre à risque
même la vie de certaines
personnes.
- Alexandre McLean pense, au
contraire, que la cohabitation
est possible, comme le démontre
l'expérience de plusieurs
grandes villes, dont Londres,
avec ses 4000 ruches, ou Paris.
- Paris a 700 ruches pour
une superficie qui est trois
fois plus petite que celle
de Montréal, t'sais, alors,
si on a à peu près 700 ruches
à Montréal, on pourrait se dire
qu'il y aurait trois fois plus
de places. Eux font ça depuis
10 ans avec succès,
ça fonctionne bien.
Ils ont des belles productions,
donc non, je pense pas qu'il y
ait un problème, tant que
c'est bien géré, tant qu'on a
des abeilles qui sont dociles
et qu'on fait bien ça, t'sais.
- Ce qui est certain, c'est que
l'engouement pour la production
de miel en ville n'a pas l'air
d'une mode passagère.
- Aujourd'hui, l'apiculture
urbaine devrait s'orienter vers
des projets communautaires,
éducatifs, et non plus vers
le désir d'une personne
d'avoir une ruche ou plusieurs
sur son toit ou son balcon.
- Ici Normand Grondin, Radio-Canada, Montréal